moments after being acquitted in his
second impeachment trial on saturday
with 57 senators voting to convict but
falling short
of the required 67 senators
donald trump immediately put out a
letter saying
he is not going away we've been
wondering will trump go away
or will he stick around in politics at
least for now
trump claims he is not going to go away
we will talk later about the
implications of this but he wrote on
saturday we'll look at his letter
i want to first thank my team of
dedicated lawyers and others for their
tireless work upholding justice and
defending truth
not exactly what they did but okay
trump says my deepest thanks as well to
all of the united states senators and
members of congress
who stood proudly for the constitution
we all revere and for the sacred legal
principles at the heart of our country
well they didn't
many of them wrongly said you can't uh
try
and or convict a former president that
is not actually the reality
constitutionally
trump goes on to say our cherished
constitutional republic was founded
on the impartial rule of law the
indispensable safeguard for our
liberties and our rights and our
freedoms
it is a sad commentary on our times that
one political party in america
is given a free pass to denigrate the
rule of law to fame law enforcement
cheer mobs excuse rioters
and transform justice into a tool of
political vengeance and persecute
blacklist cancel and suppress all people
with viewpoints with whom that which
they
with whom or which they disagree that
sounds
like what the rioters did trump's saying
that to criticize i guess democrats
he goes on and says i always have and
always will be a champion for the
unwavering rule of law
the heroes of law enforcement and the
right of americans to peacefully and
honorably debate the issues of the day
without malice and without hate this has
been yet another phase of the greatest
witch-hunt
in the history of our country no
president has ever gone through anything
like it
well no president has ever done the
things trump did and it continues
because our opponents cannot forget the
almost 75 million people
the highest number ever for a sitting
president who voted for us just a few
more short months
ago no one's forgetting them we remember
them and were horrified by them
nobody's forgotten them i also want to
convey my gratitude to the millions of
decent hard-working law-abiding god and
country-loving citizens
who have bravely supported these
important principles in these very
difficult and challenging times
our histo historic patriotic and
beautiful movement to make america great
again
has only just begun key moment
in the months ahead i have much to share
with you
and i look forward to continuing our
incredible journey together
to achieve american greatness for all of
our people there has never been anything
like it
we have so much work ahead of us and
soon we will emerge with a vision for a
bright radiant and limitless
american future together there is
nothing we cannot accomplish
trump saying we remain one people one
family and one glorious nation under god
and it's our responsibility to preserve
this magnificent inheritance for our
children
and for many gender and for generations
of americans to come
may god bless all of you and may god
forever bless the united sheish
no that's not true he did say united
states it was in writing so the slur
didn't apply
so most of what trump says is completely
backwards
but that's not surprising i wasn't
expecting donald trump to suddenly tell
the truth
but the matter of practical importance
here is that of
if and how trump will remain in politics
and remain a force in the republican
party not forever but at least for the
next few years
we know based on a poll from 10 days ago
64 percent of republican voters
said it said they would follow trump to
another party 64
two thirds almost of the republican
party
is willing to leave if trump says here's
my new party come with me
and with trump putting out a statement
like this it doesn't seem as though
trump is planning to go quietly now the
questions that remain
include will trump's involvement in
republican politics
help republicans or hurt them in 2021 in
the gubernatorial races that there are
uh will trump's involvement in the
republican party
help or hurt them in 2022 when they want
presumably
to take back control of the house of
representatives take back control of the
senate
will trump end up criminally charged in
georgia where he's under criminal
investigation
in new york in other states and
will that interfere with donald trump's
political plans
and will the republican party which for
now is still
officially speaking mostly behind donald
trump
will they sour with trump and say enough
is enough
at some point these are the questions
we don't yet know the answers but
judging from what donald trump is saying
he's going to try something in the next
few months
in terms of an involvement and we will
see how the republican party
reacts curious to know your thoughts
we'll have more coverage of this
on the david pakman show instagram page
which you can find
at david pakman show find me on
instagram at david.pacman
and we will be back right after this i
will argue
that the extremist wing of the
republican party has become too big to
fail
the radicals are too numerous
to simply go away and we'll talk about
that after the break
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing a
shirt by a company called
teddy stratford and i love these shirts
so much that i asked teddy stratford to
be a sponsor of the show
and here's why i like their shirt so
much with other slim fit button-up
shirts
you often get this weird-looking gap
between the buttons where it looks kind
of stretched out but teddy stratford
actually has a patented zipper
that's hidden underneath the buttons
which secures the shirt against your
chest so it doesn't look
stretched and most importantly it just
provides a nicer looking fit overall
and the entire shirt is specially
designed to really improve the way your
upper body looks when you're wearing it
it also has a special type of collar
that prevents it from drooping down
and spreading open which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things really do a lot to
make a big difference when you're
looking at a shirt
and that's why i like to wear teddy
stratford shirts on the show
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout